hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today we're going to examine some
strange similarities between Celtic
languages and Semitic languages we know
what the world is like in the 21st
century but what was the world like in
the first century or a thousand years
before that we have some written records
from those days but to a large extent we
have to imagine the Celtic languages and
the Semitic languages are as far as we
know entirely separate language families
the Celtic languages being a branch of
the wider indo-european language family
and the Semitic languages being a part
of the wider afro-asiatic language
family but there are a number of
curiously similar features that are
shared between the two groups of
languages I've spent some time studying
Hebrew both biblical and modern as well
as some biblical aramaic and some Arabic
later when examining insular Celtic
languages I noticed their similarities
with Semitic languages and I found them
intriguing and when I looked into it I
discovered that these similarities are
well known to linguists let's look at
some of those similarities and then
we'll look at some possible reasons for
these similarities vs o both groups of
languages are generally VSO in their
default syntax modern spoken Hebrew and
modern colloquial Arabic don't stick to
this but Biblical Hebrew and classical
Arabic as well as modern Standard Arabic
are vso generally speaking for example
charriba rasool ullah mara the man drank
water word-for-word it's drank the man
water here we can see the verb comes
first the subject comes second and the
object comes third and in Hebrew shot
AHA ishm I'm the only grammatical
difference here is that Hebrew doesn't
use the definite article to talk about
water in general but it has the same VSO
word order in Irish Thal affair Ishta
and in Welsh I thought that in Thor
these sentences are syntactically
identical to the Hebrew sentence and
almost identical to the Arabic sentence
the only difference being the definite
article inflected prepositions both
groups of languages make extensive use
of prepositions which are inflected
for person and number for example in
Hebrew there's a preposition min meaning
from me money from me min ha from you
masculine singular me math from you
feminine singular me menu from him me
manna from her and so on and similarly
in Arabic mean meanie minka minke me no
me no in Irish us awesome
Asad us Ashton and in Welsh Oh a Hanavi
a ha not t ohan over a Hana though
oh honey he possession in both groups of
languages inflected prepositions can be
used to express possession in Hebrew
Leah or yesh Leah meaning I have a
brother in Hebrew this preposition means
for or to and has a first-person
singular pronoun as a suffix in biblical
hebrew either way is correct but in
modern conversational hebrew yesh is
required in Arabic Leah you could see
this is almost the same as the Hebrew
sentence but in its more literary or
formal form its leo
with this nominative case ending oon in
Arabic there are also some other
prepositions that can show possession so
it could be la dia my E and E etc but
they're all inflected in the same way
with pranaam '''l suffixes in Irish oh
it's so harsh of them word-for-word it's
is brother at me so here again we have a
preposition inflected for first-person
singular and in Welsh I can leave out
again we have an inflected preposition
Guinea which is the first person
singular form of gun meaning with so in
all of these languages an inflected
preposition is used to show possession
obligation inflected prepositions are
also used to show obligation in other
words with the meaning of half to in
Hebrew a lile if told me stuff
meaning I have to write a letter word
for word it's on me to write a letter
this is a preposition meaning on with
first person singular suffix in Arabic
la and October is a Latin on me that I
will write a letter this preposition is
similar to the Hebrew one
and an Irish autumn it's a rescue is on
me a letter to write the key point is
this inflected preposition right here
and in Welsh and hiding me ask Ravana
there is the necessity to me write a
letter in Welsh we see a combination of
preposition and pronoun but the pronoun
is a separate word rather than an
inflection so this one is a little
different from the others result of
pronouns in relative clauses in both
Celtic languages and Semitic languages
prepositions appearing in relative
clauses include the inflected pronoun so
the person or thing referred to by the
head noun is referred to again for
example in English we say the chair
which i sat on but in these languages
it's something like the chair which I
sat on it in Hebrew a kiss I assure you
chef teah love in arabic al kursi you
lady jealous to nae in irish energy and
in welsh a guitar other than the nested
Arne definite article but no indefinite
article while it's more common among the
languages of the world to have both a
definite article and an indefinite
article or no articles at all all of the
insular Celtic languages and most of the
Semitic and afro-asiatic languages have
a definite article but no indefinite
article in Hebrew Melek means a king
Jimenez means the king this is the
definite article here ha in Arabic
melaku means a king and and manicou
means the king in irish three real and
similarly in Welsh Brandon Brandon there
are a few other well-known languages
that have a definite article but no
indefinite article such as Cassie
Icelandic and Old Norse and it's also a
feature of some constructed languages
like cinder in Quenya and Esperanto but
it's not very common and that makes this
similarity between Celtic and Semitic
stand out to me construct state genitive
both groups of languages have a feature
in which two nouns are placed one after
another and the first noun is modified
by the one that follows there can be
more than two nouns but let's keep it
simple
for example in Hebrew Delta bite the
door of the house in Arabic but
and in Irish that is at sea and in Welsh
trulicity in each of the above phrases
the structure is the same the second
noun is a dependent now and modifies the
first noun like an adjective does or
like a possessive genitive which would
normally use of in English if the phrase
is definite the definite article only
attaches to the second dependent now not
to the first one the structure alone is
enough to tell us what the relationship
between the two nouns is but in both
Irish and classical and literary Arabic
the nouns also have case forms in
classical Arabic and modern Standard
Arabic babble Beatty with nominative and
genitive case endings also an Irish the
first noun is in its nominative form and
the second noun is in its genitive form
another feature that stood out to me
when studying Semitic languages
specifically their classical forms was
the use of the word meaning and with
additional meanings that seemed quite
different for a native English speaker
and in English is a coordinating
conjunction in other words it adds one
independent clause to another but in
insular Celtic languages and Semitic
languages the equivalent of ant can also
create the meaning of a subordinate
clause it can be circumstantial like
when or as for example in Arabic anyway
on our side this means he saw me as I
was coming out wah is the word meaning
and but here it's used to mean while or
as in Irish drama she isn't selfish of
us a in the hobble the word August's is
the word for and but here it means while
or as the word for and can also create
contrastive meaning similar to although
or but for example in hebrew vy he of
bahala thought who the holy let's meet
slime high Elohim this means and there
was famine in all the lands but in all
the land of Egypt there was food it's
interesting to note that in English the
word while can be used with both a
contrastive meaning and with a
circumstantial meaning so it might be a
good alternative translation for these
words meaning and in demonstrating these
similarities I've been using Semitic
languages but the same similarities can
be found in other languages in other
branches
of the afro-asiatic language family not
only the Semitic branch languages like
amazeen also known as Berber and ancient
Egyptian also correspond in similar ways
now the question is why do those
similarities exist between insular
Celtic languages and Semitic and
afro-asiatic languages they could just
be a set of typological similarities
meaning that these features arose
similarly but independently of each
other and not as a result of contact the
other possibility of course is that they
arose as a result of contact celtic
languages now are mostly limited to
Great Britain and Ireland as well as
Brittany in France but in the past they
were all over Europe including the
Iberian Peninsula right across from
Africa and including Asia Minor right
around present-day Ankara Turkey not too
far from the Levant to the south that
means that there were significant
chances of contact with afro-asiatic
languages but some linguists theories go
back further than that and they suggest
that before Indo Europeans arrived in
Western Europe much of the area was
populated by speakers of an early
afro-asiatic language and later they
adopted indo-european languages while on
the continent the number of
indo-europeans was large enough that the
earlier languages didn't leave much of
an influence in Ireland and the British
Isles the population of pre
indo-europeans was large enough that
their speech patterns influenced the
insular Celtic languages as they
developed so the theory is that the
insular Celtic languages have an
afro-asiatic substrate such theories are
inconclusive and unproven but are they
far-fetched
not really we know that continuous human
settlement in Ireland and Great Britain
began thousands of years before the
arrival of the celts and we know that
while there were hunter-gatherers in
europe already early farmers began
migrating to Europe from the Near East
Anatolia and the Levant during the
Neolithic period one theory the
Anatolian theory suggests that these
farmers brought indo-european with them
but it's more widely believed that
indo-europeans arrived later during the
Chaco lithic and bronze periods if
that's the case what kind of language
did the farmers migrating from the Near
East speak it's possible that they
spoken afro-asiatic language one
linguist Theo van Amman has the
rised that between 5,000 and 2500 BCE
seafaring people's whom he refers to as
paleo Phoenicians spread the megalithic
culture of large stone structures all
the way up the Atlantic coast to Ireland
the British Isles and beyond and brought
their afro-asiatic language with them he
refers to this language or these
languages as somatic since they may have
belonged to a branch of afro-asiatic
that was close to semitic but has since
died off except as a substratum in
indo-european languages
Theo venneman goes even further to
suggest that SEMATECH languages are the
source of some non-indo-european
vocabulary in Germanic languages again
many linguists have challenged his
theories and emphasized their
speculative nature the truth is that we
don't know exactly what kind of
languages were spoken in prehistoric
times or what kind of contact they had
with each other what we do know is that
the insular Celtic languages are
curiously different from other
indo-european languages in certain ways
and in those same ways they seem similar
to Semitic and afro-asiatic languages
beyond that imagining how that situation
came about is merely a fascinating
exercise the question of the day for
speakers of Celtic languages and Semitic
or afro-asiatic languages are you
surprised by these similarities between
the two groups and for other people do
your languages share any of the features
that Celtic and afro-asiatic languages
have in common if you enjoyed this video
be sure to check out the various lengths
okis social media accounts like Facebook
YouTube and Instagram and once again
thank you to all of my wonderful patreon
supporters especially these people right
here on the screen who are my top tier
patreon supporters so many extra special
thanks to them and to everyone thank you
for watching and have a nice day
[Music]
you
[Music]